Es ist der absolute horror der golfstrom fällt aus und in europa bricht eine eiszeit an der golfstrom ist ja eine art warmwasserheizung
So nordeuropa und es gibt viele forschungsteams die immer wieder
eindringlich davor warnen dass sich der golfstrom abschwächt ja vielleicht bald sogar komplett zum erliegen kommt
Ausgelöst durch den klimawandel ein hoch spannendes thema das ihr euch bei whatsapp gewünscht, habt wie an meine nummer kommt erfahrt ihr am ende
Des videos also warum ist der golfstrom so wichtig und droht uns tatsächlich eine eiszeit falls
er versiegt hat sie willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Der golfstrom eine art klima motor für europa dieses strömungs system kommt aus der karibik genau genommen
Von den bahamas auf seinem weg erwärmt sich das wasser auf bis zu 30 grad celsius und seine wirkung zeigt sich bis zur küste norwegens
den golfstrom kann man sich vorstellen wie eine riesige
umwälzpumpe denn zum einen fließt nahe an der oberfläche
Warmes tropisches wasser über den atlantik in richtung europa aus dem nordatlantik strom verdunstet wasser die salzkonzentration
des meeres steigt zudem kühlt sich der strom ab beide faktoren führen dazu dass das wasser
Dichter und schwerer wird singt in die tiefsee hinab gelang zurück nach
südwesten bis zum südatlantik und zwar als kalte tiefenströmungen somit
verbindet der golfstrom vier der fünf ozeane miteinander
Forschungsteams bezeichnen ihn auch als das globale
förderband von meeresströmungen das absinken
des wassers passiert vor allem in den nördlichen breiten der labrador und der grönlandsee 17 millionen kubikmeter wasser pro sekunde
Stürzt in eine tiefe von bis zu 4000 metern der größte wasserfall der welt und zwar zwischen grönland und spitzbergen
Tatsächlich 15 mal so viel wasser wie alle flüsse der welt zusammen wow
durch dieses absinken des wassers entsteht ein sog und eben der zieht den golfstrom richtung europa
Im großen und ganzen haben wir es in mittel und nordeuropa dem golfstrom zu verdanken dass hier vor allem. Im winter eher
mildere temperaturen herrschen es gibt schätzungen nach
Denen es ohne ihn in nord- und nordwesteuropa, im durchschnitt bis zu zehn grad kälter wäre dann
Sähe die landschaft eher so aus wie in kanada
Karg und eis bedeckt statt grüner wiesen und wälder die mündung der elbe beispielsweise wäre wohl wie die hudson bay
monatelang vereist die entscheidende frage lautet inwieweit
Beeinflusst der klimawandel den golfstrom und besteht die gefahr dass er komplett abreißt
genau dieser frage den forschungsteams seit den 80er jahren nach denn ihr könnt euch vorstellen
Die antwort darauf ist vielleicht entscheidend für das leben auf der erde es gibt viele verschiedene modellrechnungen
aber eines ist ganz sicher der klimawandel hat
Auswirkungen auf den golfstrom diskutiert wird nur noch wie fatal die folgen wohl sein werden in früheren analysen
Könnte sich der strom um höchstens 20 prozent abschwächen selbst wenn sich die kohlendioxid-konzentration
gegenüber der vorindustriellen zeit verdoppeln würde die sogenannte
atlantik mehr die
Nova turning the collection ist demnach ziemlich stabil so die annahme andere aktuelle studien dagegen behaupten das gegenteil
Demnach könnten die riesigen strömungen sogar komplett abreißen wenn sich der co2 gehalt verdoppelt es sind mehrere faktoren des
klimawandels die den golfstrom schwächen und lahmlegen könnten zum einen erwärmt die steigende globale
temperatur das wasser dieses wird leichter das strömungs system verliert an antrieb und weniger warmes wasser
gelangt nach, nordeuropa auch das abschmelzen der pole und des grönlandeises lässt das wasser
Im endeffekt leichter werden denn dadurch nimmt der salzgehalt des meerwassers ab eine weitere rolle spielt das auftauen der permafrostböden
wodurch sibirischen flüsse mehr süßwasser in die nördlichen meere spielen
Im vergleich zur eisschmelze wohl aber nur ein kleiner faktor dieses wissen führt dazu dass klima forschungsteams den golfstrom sehr genau
Im blick haben fest steht er hat sich in den letzten 100 jahren um zirka
1,2 grad erwärmt der atlantik um 0,5 das zeigen daten und modellsimulationen von 1900 bis
2008 doch es gibt auch einige experten und expertinnen die dem golfstrom längst nicht eine so bedeutende rolle zuschreiben
Sie halten den einfluss, des golfstroms für überschätzt deutschland würde sich bei einem kompletten zusammenbruch
Um durchschnittlich ein bis zwei grad abkühlen und weiter selbst wenn der golfstrom, im schlimmsten fall komplett
Zum erliegen käme würden wir demnach wohl
Um sibirische winter drum herumkommen denn die klimaerwärmung
Würde diesen effekt wieder ausgleichen dennoch in island und skandinavien hätte ein
lahmgelegte golfstrom weitaus größere folgen die eisdecke würde anwachsen die temperaturen
Im winter um bis zu sieben grad absinken dies würde zum einen die fischerei und damit auch die wirtschaft ja ziemlich stark
beeinträchtigen zum anderen würde auch das regionale klima in vielen teilen der welt beeinflusst beispielsweise
Im mittel und südamerika da sich der gürtel über dem tropischen atlantik in richtung
Süden verschieben würde aber auch an den amerikanischen
Ostküsten würde der meeresspiegel steigen hat er ja auch schon begonnen genauso wie die anzahl der harry kennt so oder so
scheinen die veränderung des golfstroms
Erhebliche folgen zu haben welche genau das werden wir wohl erst in der zukunft erfahren und wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
Golfstrom und zu den klimaänderungen dadurch erfahren wollt und zu allen anderen themen dann
Endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp da müsst ihr einfach nur hier draufklicken dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und dadurch mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel weltweites wetterchaos hat begonnen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran